all right so so justin what what
illusion do you have for me and dj
khaled right now with your cue
my son jackson he's making his uh his
network television debut right now i
like it
i've been teaching him some mind reading
and we're gonna do that because listen
i've learned he loves
when my wife and i read him books at
night he loves he loves books
i know i was telling him that he but
we've had so much time to
to to read you know here's some milk
he's gonna get warmed up we burned
through dr
seuss right away we kind of got into the
sophisticated stuff wuthering heights
war and peace i mean like we're digging
deep and just last night my wife and i
began what i believe
to be one of the greatest literary works
of our time i'm sure you'll agree
uh tmz's book of celebrity fails
and uh every page is a different
celebrity and it's kind of all the
stupid stuff they've said like uh
let's see paris hilton said what's
walmart do they sell wall stuff
we're going to do something with this
book but first my son has made a
prediction here
okay jack's prediction tax prediction
i'm just going to place this over here
in the plan
we'll get back to that so there's a 129
pages in the book okay kelly give me a
random number between 1
and 129 18 18.
okay so we will turn to page
18. page 18 is
oh nice i can't see you
oh tom cruise there we go tom cruise
could have been could have been so many
people tom cruise now
i cannot believe this my son jackson
knew that you would pick
tom cruise they did not oh he knew
this kid's a prodigy all right in his
envelope
there's no way that that envelope says
tom how in the hell would that oh sorry
baby
ears your mouth in this envelope my son
placed a photograph
to be impressive inside here is a
picture of tom cruise
i'm gonna freak out i don't understand
how that's even possible
i'm gonna pull it out it is a photograph
one photograph
of tom cruise for two months
not tom christmas no it's not it's it's
absolutely
not jackson but he did know you would
pick tom cruise
okay it was a dad joke i'm trying to
teach him that too okay he got dressed
this morning
and put on his onesie he picked a very
specific onesie just for you
wow
that is so not that's dude that's not
even possible
tell them how you did it guys i can't
even bully i can't see it i'm so hot
right now my pets are sweaty i don't
even understand what just happened
oh my gosh you are so talented and
gifted or actually no that's
that's that's crazy it's all the baby
right here that was
crazy subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going